[Music]
welcome to Dragon Age Inquisition this
is the first in a series of video
showcasing the gameplay features of
Bioware's latest RPG this segment
details the game's flexible multifaceted
combat systems player choice dictates
combat in Dragon Age Inquisition every
encounter can be approached in a
multitude of ways using a combination of
real time action and the pause and play
tactical camera players seeking a more
action-oriented approach and lead from
the front with a gracefully wielding
daggers staggering a foe of the
Warhammer who are unleashing devastating
spells Inquisitor will be supported in
combat by a party of unique and amazing
allies from the mighty Iron Bowl to the
powerful mage to the end each brings a
specialized mix of abilities and
weaponry to the battlefield you can
customize your party in advance by
setting preferences for a specific
ability or for more measured strategic
approach to combat the player can issue
commands at the heat of battle using the
tactical camera this feature removes
time from the equation allowing you to
get more information about the enemies
you're facing in order to tailor your
attack each party member can be selected
and given a variety of commands from
attacking specific targets moving to a
point defending an area
reviving a down party member or using
potions poisons or elixir suit commands
are clearly reflected on the screen and
communicate each followers objective
after issuing orders the player can
restart time starting and stopping at
any point to adjust their approach or
see how their tactics have played out
for example in this maneuver the player
strategically blocking off the enemies
in order to divide and conquer the
camera can be adjusted for a big-picture
view or pulled in tightly taking the
omen of choice even further the player
can explore or enter battle playing as
any one of the followers that make up
their party battles in real time become
pulse-pounding affairs where every
attack of manoeuvre can spell the
difference between victory or defeat one
thing that remains consistent is the
challenging aspect of combat Dragon Age
Inquisition each encounter from swarms
of demons a towering high Dragons will
take the full force of the Inquisitor
and party to overcome
you